[Music]
hi there
[Music]
dear friends we're in front of turnum
station what are we doing here we're not
going anywhere
we've come to the florist now the wood
is muslim
he was a christian before so obviously
you are aware of what happened in sri
lanka
and there was uh seven eight explosions
three or four of them
were in churches where people were
celebrating easter
and innocent people died and obviously
this reminds us of what happened at
christchurch yeah
and obviously what happened is sad and
as a muslim community we saw the love
and the support that people gave us yeah
and i thought it's incompetent upon us
that the least that we can do is show
some kind of love back
and to show them that this is not going
to divide us there was a few churches
that got uh
yeah yeah so basically uh we're going to
be visiting some churches we're muslims
but obviously you know i've been in
christ church and so basically we're
looking for some bunch of flowers
we're looking for we've got a budget
around 100 pounds
it's probably better if you if you go
inside the garden center and up the
stairs and you can talk to the girls up
there they'll be able to maybe make it
oh can you make one
all right all right
okay so what we're gonna do guys now
we're gonna go upstairs and hopefully
um get some done okay so basically um
so the lady who served in us um four but
she gave one free she said it's for a
good cause
so we're gonna leave a link do check her
out inshallah you can come here okay
flowers from here that's very really
nice of her
okay thank you very much
okay thank
thank you very much take care have a
nice day bye
okay guys so we have got the flowers
what we're gonna do now is we're gonna
go head to the car
and we're gonna uh search for churches
near us
but before we do that we're going to
write some notes and write some nice
uh send a nice message with them with
the flowers
so not only do the flowers smell nice
but hopefully what they read will be
nice
so us
[Music]
closed but we rang this up they're open
we're gonna go inside follow us and
let's see what happens
hi sir
[Music]
on behalf of the muslim community uh
basically as you know what happened in
sri lanka oh yes and yeah
it's okay um so we just wanted to say
you know um to show our support and that
these people are not going to divide us
i know they're trying to do that and
christ church
and sadly these crazy people
done it as supposedly a revenge attack
on their behalf because the muslim
community doesn't
represent them and they don't represent
us so we just wanted to say you know
just to take the time that we came
inside so we had a look
well i just want to say thank you and uh
thank you
you'll always be my brothers yes thank
you very much and you will be our sister
humanity
thank you have a nice day um
well this is um actually an act of
kindness that we are because of the
attacks in sri lanka against the
churches
so we are youtubers online and what we
do is
we happen to be muslims but we felt like
we felt compelled in fact
to come to a community that is attached
to the church
to give our condolences
welcome to michael's church it's very
beautiful
have you got the flowers with you yeah
we are in a catholic church this is uh
was built in the 1900s
um these are all the church goals as you
can see that's another with the flowers
um yeah so we're here got three more
three more churches not much to go to
so the reason we're doing this obviously
you know there was a christchurch attack
and
either christian the jewish community as
a whole you know this showed support to
the muslims
and we want to do the same because we
know in sri lanka uh taps happen towards
the churches in
easter so we found the need because we
come from an organization called salam
sharing the affliction of love and mercy
which wanted to give these flowers
obviously to you guys
uh but we'll leave it there but after
you can hopefully
smell them and put them somewhere but we
just want to thank you and just
say that you know we're really sorry for
what's happened and hopefully this will
not divide us
you know and bring this course together
because these people's aims and
objectives
they just want us to hate each other and
that's not going to happen and we just
want to say thank you for your time and
hopefully if you can just go and put it
yeah probably on the hope you know it
says hope i'll probably put it on there
for a day and have more meaning
we need to dialogue with christians jews
sikhs hindus whatever whoever it may be
yes we have our differences
but also that we have things that are in
common as well
and also if i may add to this um if
there's a video
whether the person is real or not
claiming to be from isis
using nasheed and quran in the
background and then
putting his finger in the in the air and
saying inshallah and then
after saying we're going to kill all of
you what
is out there to counter that because
it's almost become like oh but
the christians should know majority of
christians know but you know what
sometimes
the action speaks louder than words and
it really touches people
when we go out of our way to do these
things it's symbolic
i get it but nonetheless it has to
happen
i'll tell you why i'll give you a very
fine example when the prophet peace be
on
[Music]
and he quoted the verse from the quran
yeah that's messengers before that
passed away are you going to turn back
on your heels do you know what's more
profound about this
when the sahabah heard this abdullah if
i'm a mistake and said that all of them
acted like they never heard this verse
ever because reminder benefits a
believer
so like you said oh the christians they
might think no reminder
yeah you have to remind them you have to
remind them
yeah so yes we're going to leave this
here
as you can see the words hope and
hopefully we can
hopefully we can have hope in humanity
and one another
and not let people divide us
the doors open that's always a good sign
open door is a
welcoming home i just made that up
so we are here to give our condolences
um to what happened in sri lanka and
um it was this was christians um
our brothers who got attacked we from
the muslim community
and we felt like compelled to increase
our interaction with our christian
brothers and humanity just because of
there's a small group of people who are
causing a lot of division
and taking harmony away so we're here
on behalf of the muslims to say
brothers and sisters we have uh gone to
five different churches
give them flowers had discussions with
them it was amazing
i want to recite surah imran verse 113
where allah says
[Music]
that not all of them are alike among the
people of the book there are those who
are steadfast
they recite the verses of allah in the
right hours and they prostrate
themselves
now we cannot compare
the christians the what happened at
christ church
a man who claimed he was a christian
two people who are peaceful christians
we cannot and allah is telling us
yes these people they are not the same
they are some who worship allah
now by doing this we wanted to show
people this world also
that as muslims there are good and bad
we do not come and say okay black people
are all gangsters
yeah christians are all pedophiles
muslims are all terrorists yeah we do
not go and generalize we just want to
show the importance
of coming together and conveying the
message and we have to now we are not in
no way shape or form saying that we
found the solution now we've given some
flowers hearing
put us on the back yep well done no no
no we've made a solution no
but it is a step in the right direction
and that's this is what we have to do
we need to carry on giving dawah because
if we don't and we're just quiet we're
just like robots we don't do nothing
what's going to happen is people's
misconceptions are going to grow
yeah and um also what i wanted to say is
um
especially as as someone who's who has
grown around christian um
culture yeah i i understand
that you know when you don't engage when
there's no engagement at all
yeah and and like you were saying before
there are certain people going to say oh
look at these kumbaya
like flowers is just a symbolic
meaning but the gesture i think is very
important
but what i find shocking today actually
mesmerizing at the same
time yeah it's what we heard from those
oh yes yes yes what they were saying to
us
how unexpected it was because you know
let's face this i think a lot of it as
well went over the head of other people
because sri lanka is so far away
like it wasn't as we don't keep it in
the western
you know i wouldn't say that but it
wasn't as
true yeah but it was not as much in the
media
people were like not [ __ ] like yes it
was not a topic like notre dame for
example i saw like
there was a statistic that when notre
dame happened
in sri lanka yeah that that churches
online were seven times highest seven to
one
yes to the searches about what happened
in sri lanka and it shows you where
the relevancy is so i think people
basically were quite surprised that we
came and they really hit
them you know emotionally and
spiritually
and i think that's very important to do
these things even these small things
it's important like to do them
however we can't not bank on them we
can't not bank on symbolism
there has to be an anticipation that
these things are continuing to happen so
people muslims muslim female women
especially
christians we have to be very vigilant
and being vigilant does not mean only in
terms of you being protected
but vigilant being also in terms of
having
your ear out because there are small
fractions of people who are causing
these divisions
and you don't need millions of
extremists on both sides
to cause damage you need a small amount
so be vigilant
also means to reject extremists
um converse and talks from the far right
for example who will
exploit this situation and say well look
again the muslims that's why
the christchurch guy was justified to do
it and i understand there is
a lot of angry white male or angry
westerners
and have resentment for what happened in
the west but i think
tit for that and if an eye in this case
is not going to solve the issue
you have to be more introspective and
proactive
and i feel like this yeah i don't know
yeah and i just want to wrap up brother
and sisters uh
uh thank you guys for watching inshallah
uh this is from salaam inshallah sharing
affection love of mercy to support our
organization there's gonna be link at
the description box below inshallah
do um help us however you can share
share this with your friends and family
inshallah
and hate is not going to divide us and
you are going to see this inshallah for
yourself
assalamualaikum